you know it's funny I saw someone just
randomly post the quote this morning
where there's tears there's hope and I
just thought that's a nice sentiment
then I watched this episode and I liked
it even more the doctor falls so I'm
going to get the two major bullet points
out of the way is this as good an
episode as the previous one world enough
in time no is it the kind of drop off
from penultimate episode to final
episode of the series that Kevin sent to
hell bench was know so while it was not
able to maintain the high of the
previous episode it didn't nosedive into
what the heck was that and I'm not going
to rehash myself on hell but I know
there are some people who really liked
that finale I've talked about it in more
than one video before it just didn't
work for me it was weird to me this I
got immediately I knew what it was going
for and I understand why it was
presented the way it was coming off of
the previous episode they're not feeling
very of two minds in regards to sort of
the pacing of it oh yeah
reminder spoilers there will be so the
whole pace of the thing it was pretty
slow it was pretty quiet for most of it
there were a lot of quiet moments and
there was part of me that had kind of
wanted a more rip-roaring episode you
know coming off of the high that was the
end of the previous episode and I still
kind of wish we got that but at the same
time most of my favorite moments from
the episode were the quiet moments they
were Missy and the master together they
were the doctor and bill in the barn
they were the goodbye with nardole they
were the doctor and bill in that field
when she says you said you could fix me
were you lying no were you right no I
love that because you know he was
absolutely sincere when he said he could
fix her he was just wrong that's that's
heartbreaking in the best way and there
were lots of little moment it's funny
much like the overall pace and feel of
the thing there were lots of little
moments as that went on
I was like oh I don't like that they did
that but then something will happen go
oh okay well now it's working like when
they jumped ahead two weeks and I just
see Bill in the bar I'm like oh they go
so he just fixed her great then she got
the Mara Mike oh okay we just want to be
sure that Pearl Maki gets to actually
appear in the last episode even though
she wasn't fixed in terms of her
resolution I liked it I thought it was
sweet III want to go back and re-watch
the pilot now again but um I kind of
like how that came full circle this is a
version of the companion getting to go
out and experience the universe without
the doctor that I like much more than
what happened with Clara at the end of
hell-bent I promise I'll stop bringing
that episode up but it worked for me it
was nice it was sweet it felt like a
earned call back especially with the
reference to Tears which we've been
getting references to across this
episode already so it felt like it was
properly pan
planted they did the callback correctly
and yeah it worked for me one of the
little cheesy maybe but it didn't not to
a degree that it felt like a cop-out
like it's the doctor and fixers that
would have been cheesy in an unearned
fashion this didn't quite read like that
for me so that worked for me um Capaldi
was great I mean he just he just was and
I loved his determination and it looks
like we're going to be going into the
Christmas special doing something that I
kind of secretly hoped would be the case
which is we're basically going to get a
whole story of him fighting back to
regeneration the entire time
a Mendes of course the other thing about
the very end of this episode I will come
back to that um I'm kind of up to lines
on the inclusion of Johnson's master
because I don't I don't know how much he
added now I will again say his reveal in
the previous episode and especially his
work as mr. razor was awesome loved it
but his actual use in this episode I I
don't think he needed to be there he
didn't write it down
he wasn't bad he wasn't a bad element I
just I feel like his inclusion wasn't
necessary it
felt like a gimmick and I get ultimately
it was how do we kill Missy in a way
that prevents her from taking up her you
know taking up a stand alongside the
doctor
and feels like the right way to do it
and the idea of the master killing
himself cuz he doesn't like what he
becomes later it kind of works it kind
of fits but I don't I felt like really
up until the two of them in front of the
lift up until that moment I didn't feel
like it needed to be him like they could
have found another way to kill Missy and
disable regeneration or whatever I did
the master is still coming back it may
not be missing specifically they would
still find a way to bring the master
back they may or may not explain it they
kill them without having regeneration
kick in before and they brought him back
they brought back Davros you know
without explaining how that haven't
eaten the maps is coming back but
Michelle Gomez as Missy was so good she
really she is so good in this part and
I'm going to miss her terribly but at
the same time I do realize that a big
part of what I really liked about her
was her chemistry with Capaldi and she
may not have been able to retain that
with whoever the new doctor ends up
being so I'm okay because Capaldi is
leaving with Missy heard her 10 years
miss the ending as well and it possible
she might kind of come back but official
word is she's done with a role so that's
my expectation um I'm going to miss her
though she was really good and again the
the whole like the notion and the way
she was closed out especially than she
dies live in joy oh of course I shot
myself with the baggage she just laughs
at it that that was good and it felt
right but I don't know man Johnson's
mastery was just kind of there he was
kind of just spinning his wheels up
until he did that so again didn't drag
the episode down I just I almost kind of
feel like if you weren't going to do
more with
that it wasn't worth the inclusion
because the the idea of having him in
having two masters in the story feels
like this should be a major deal except
for his part in the story it kind of
isn't so it's an I don't know it's
something that I had to take to again to
call it a negative but it's like a
didn't really need that I like um that
there was basically one line that
explains the lay every and all
continuity issue with Cybermen in terms
of their appearance across the series
how they look different how did they get
here weren't they all destroyed that
edit that end the doctor just saying
we've got parallel evolutions this is
what this is what humanity tends to do
when it's got the proper level of
technology and the right circumstances
happen this keeps happening and I kind
of like that as an idea I mean if you
want to be doom and gloom about it you
could read it as humanity will always
become Cybermen I don't
I choose not to read it as that I see it
a bit more like this is one of the you
know likely paths that humans tend to
take not always but it can't happen with
the right technology level in the right
circumstances and I kind of like that I
kind of dig it and it in one line it
basically explains away every kind of
new ad error where every fan has ever
gone but wait these Cybermen look like
the parallel universe Cybermen but they
don't have to see where are they from
who cares they came from a parallel
evolution or they were from on this or
from tellus who cares it doesn't matter
we've had it we've had a nice one-line
explanation where we can stop worrying
about it
nardole had a lot of good moments Matt
Lucas I he's another one I'm going to
miss I and and again but at this point
there's a part of me that was resistant
to the idea of Moffat leaving Capaldi
leaving bill leaving Nardo leaving Missy
leaving all at once I there's a part of
me that was really hoping for some
strand of continuity between
regeneration but at this point I do have
to accept that a huge part of what I
liked about pretty much all these
elements that I just named was how they
interacted with
haldi specifically and you know what
they may not have that same chemistry
with a new doctor so I've kind of come
to terms with that again though I am
going to miss nardole I'm going to miss
bill I'm going to miss Missy I'm really
going to miss Capaldi but we got at
least one more with him when David
Bradley returning to the role of the
first doctor having already played
William Hartnell in the the BBC special
story of time and space I can't remember
now it was really good though and he was
really good playing William Hartnell and
by extension playing the William
Hartnell version of the doctor I think I
had heard at one point I don't know if
it was a rumor or if it was confirmed
one hour I think I had have heard that
he might be appearing so well I hadn't
been expecting it I wasn't counting down
to it or anything once um you know he
was there and I like I heard somebody
moving this home like it's going to be
him and it was and I like that I like
that a lot
it's it's the kind of thing that I
really like in this in this case but I'm
a little nervous about the precedent it
sets I say precedent isn't it's not the
first time that a different actor will
be playing a specific incarnation of the
doctor they had a different actor play
the first doctor in the five doctors I
can't remember that actor's name
unfortunately I'll put it down there but
it so it has been done before um but it
hasn't been done in the modern era so in
a lot of ways I don't I don't assume
that the precedent set in the classic
era are going to be upheld in the modern
era I kind of take the modern era a
little bit separately so having that get
established makes me nervous about
possible future show runners who just
start you know casting new actors as the
older versions of the doctor and I'm not
a big fan of that idea like add
something that happens regularly I'm
looking forward to this one cuz again
I've seen David Bradley in this role and
I know we can do it I know he can do it
well but it's the sort of thing that I
think could get gimmicky and runs the
risk of basically devaluing the original
ray'll because you know it's saying oh
well yeah that actor did it but here's
another one who does it just as well and
you know that's it's not inherently
disrespectful because again if you do it
properly it can work but it's the sort
of thing that could very easily become
disrespectful if you either get an actor
who doesn't properly honor the part or
you door it just feels like creatively
you're just doing it for no particular
reason you're just doing it because you
can so who cares that you know we had an
older actor in there dead just get
somebody new and again not getting that
vibe off of David Bradley in this it
feels right it's going to be a
regeneration story it's going to be a
Christmas special he's coming off of
fighting Mondas Cybermen Mondas Cybermen
we will cause the first doctor to
regenerate into the second so in this
specific case I am digging it I just
hope that future show runners don't
don't sort of take it as basically a
green light to do that whenever they
feel like it because I don't want that I
think the other reason I don't want I
don't want it to become a regular thing
is that feels like the first step
towards like ever know and then on
Doctor Who boards or fan sites or
whatever I see somebody be like oh can
you regenerate into Matt Smith again or
into David Tennant again I'm like oh
let's not what I love I love David
Tennant I love Matt Smith in the part
but I want the doctor to always be an
evolution forward the doctor as a
character specifically I mean the show
can look back call back bring back
companions bring back you know villains
and aliens and all that and that great
love it but I feel like the doctor needs
to continue to evolve and any new actor
can certainly take their cues from
whatever previous incarnation they like
but I just I don't like the idea of just
sort of regressing back up oh let's just
bring back the old guy that everybody
liked and yeah I don't ever want that to
happen I guess I'm nervous that this you
know casting of a newer actor in an
older version of the doctor feels like a
half step towards that but now that I
say that out loud I think I'm just being
paranoid because I guess it's something
that I don't want to happen I guess I'm
just overly wary of anything that could
feasibly lead to that
on the line so I think yeah I think I'm
maybe hitting a step too far for that so
forget that but yeah it was good um I
feel like you need to watch it again to
make the column whether or not I want to
call it great it was interesting because
the whole episode had the vibe of a
regeneration episode even though he
didn't regenerate in this episode and
under other other circumstances I might
have gone that's really annoying but in
this case it still worked from because
it was still a farewell episode for so
many other characters so I was okay that
it had that feeling of regeneration that
feeling of finality that feeling of
saying farewell even though the doctor
was not the one saying farewell because
we failed to say farewell to Missy to
the Johnson master to nardole to Bill so
there was a lot that it felt right that
the atmosphere felt like a goodbye even
though the doctor himself gets one more
adventure I'm just hoping that the
Christmas special is going to be more of
a rip-roaring adventure and less of a
melancholy because I feel as we've not
we've had the the melancholy you know
the doctor's death is inevitable episode
here so I'm hoping they don't revisit
that vibe in the next one it was part of
why I don't really like time that the
the time of the doctor is I don't like
that vibe for regeneration stories
especially I like something more you
know balls-to-the-wall more just let's
go nuts let's have a nice final roller
coaster and so I'm hoping that with sort
of the farewell feeling out of the way
we will get that with the Christmas
special we'll find out when we get there
now we've got what five months
BBC could you surprise me and not
announce who the next Doctor is between
our men and have it be a shock when it
shows up I know that won't happen but I
can dream then you know what props to of
them for keeping a lid on at this point
because the last I had heard that is
being said that the next doctor has me
cast but they haven't said who it is so
the longer you want to wait on that I'm
totally okay with it so I think that
wraps up my thoughts on this particular
episode that's it for series 10
yeah I'm going to call it Capaldi's best
series I think each series he was in got
better and yeah this was really good so
the doctor falls what were your thoughts
on it whatever they were drop something
down with the comments let's talk about
it don't forget to like subscribe check
me out on Twitter at council of geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast i am also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast both available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]